Olivier Fabre bonjour bonjour Véronique
merci de nous recevoir ici dans votre
boutique de la cour des centurs à
Versailles merci c'est juste un
enchantement on ne sait où poser les
yeux tout est merveilleux et donc vous
êtes gantier depuis c'est donc la 4e
génération voilà depuis 1924 depuis 1924
et euh les racines de ces gants sont à
mot dans l'Avon si je puis dire voilà
alors racontez-moi un peu l'histoire de
cette ganterie on dit ganterie ganterie
oui tout à fait manufacture de gants
atelier de gants ganterie d'accord euh
donc mon grand-père en fait a créé la
ganterie en 1924 et à l'époque il était
jeendarm à cheval en Algérie donc rien à
voir et à l'âge de 40 ans il était à la
retraite et donc il a décidé de revenir
sur ses pas à mot où son frère avait
déjà un atelier de gant où ils sont mis
à travailler ensemble et ils ont créé
maison Fabre donc là est en 1924 chez
eux dans mot au bord du th dans une
petite maison assez humble et sur trois
étages et ils se sont spécialisés dans
les gants blancs bon c'était une époque
où tout mortitpp au métier de gendarme
ou rien à voir non non rien à voir avec
l'administration c'était plutôt par
rapport au fait que on ne sortait pas
sans ces gants et que tout le monde
avait des gants de cérémonie on portait
des gants pour toutes les occasions on
allait à la messe on faisait tout avec
des gants on comp blanc forcément blanc
alors lui il faisait que du blanc à ce
moment du blanc pardon je vous coupe en
peau ou du blanc de l'agneau oui oui de
l'agneau que du cuir donc à ce moment-là
en 1924 il y avait déjà 67 gantiers à
mot donc mot se positionnait comme cap
mondial déjà du gant et on vendait des
gants partout et c'est vrai que le
succès était au rendez-vous immédiat bon
en même temps ils
avaient c'était à une époque où c'était
facile de les vendre et puis la qualité
était au rendez-vous il y avait une
autoriété de la ville une énergie de
deux frères et tout a joué bon après il
y a eu la guerre et il a eu deux enfants
donc mon grand-père a repris
l'entreprise en
1946 puisque nous avons fermé pendant la
périe Ie de la guerre et et là il a
rencontré ma
grand-mèreuseose la fameuse rose rose on
reviendra sur rose rose en fait c'est
vraiment à la fois et le prénom et la
fleur qui vraiment aujourd'hui nous
donne beaucoup d'élan à travers les
gants parfumés et le reste vous me
parlez des années 50 donc on en est
peut-être on est peut-être en 60 62 55
60 voà et alors graskali justement qui
il y a un pont magnifique d' toute façon
mot est la capitale du pont puisqu'on a
le viaduc de Miot qui est le plus haut
pont du monde voilà le pont entre Grace
Kelly qui acheté ses gants chez ma
grand-mère et euh alors il y avait elle
avait alors en fait comment ça s'est
passé c'est qu'essentiellement l'
aacheté chez Dior euh pour les gants et
que nous produisions les gants de Dior
et euh il lui est arrivé plusieurs fois
d'acheter des gants maison Fabre euh
dans une boutique qui était rue drivoli
euh puisque nous la fornition aussi
voilà elle n'est jamais venue à
milionell mais nous avons eu
d'autres personnes on a eu madame
Pompidou madame de funess on a eu pas
mal de de personnalités qui sont déplacé
jusqu'à pendant oui la Grande Vadrouille
1973 en loser il tourne la Grande
Vadrouille on voit arriver à l'atelier
en rollroyce madame de funess et Claude
Pompidou qui rempl le coffre de la Rolls
et c'était vraiment incroyable parce que
là on a à l'atelier à peu près 350
personnes dans les années
65 68 ce qui veut dire que en 50 on a
déménagé on s'est installé dans un
nouvel atelier que ma grand-mère a créé
a développé a construit dans mot où nous
sommes toujours aujourd'hui et c'est
dans cet atelier qu'on a pu grandir
parce que la maison familiale des années
1924 c'était trop petit c'était déjà
rempli évidemment donc là on est en
plein boom on est en plein boom et donc
le le le fameux pont le fameux pont
voilà c'està-dire que grce Kelly avec ma
grand-mère et puis je reçois un coup de
téléphone au printemps 2012 voilà là on
a fait on a pris VO oui pour aujourd'hui
pour le pour le film Grace de Monaco et
et et donc du coup c'est la production
du film qui nous demande après des
recherche euh grâce à la maison Dior
merci euh si nous sommes intéressés pour
refaire les gants pour le film alors
avec un joli petit livre que nous avons
à l'atelier àot dans lequel il y a
toutes les scènes où il peut y avoir des
gants tout toutes les couleurs des des
vêtements mais aussi les accessoires
c'est-à-dire chapeau écharpe sac à main
chaussures ceinture et euh et et ainsi
pour pouvoir construire un plan de
collection avec une vingtaine de paires
qui ont été réalisé pour Nicole kitman
et puis quelques paires pour d'autres
acteurs du film donc vous votre je vous
ai dit challenge vous m'avz dit non
épopé c'est oui parce que cette belle
époque des gants c'est un peu retombé
malheureusement donc là on en reparle
grâce au au film de Grass Kelly à toute
votre actualité parce que vous êtes
aussi les gantiers de sexon The City de
la Belle et la Bête de mal
fil de thâ voilà donc finalement c'est
un peu le R par qu'on a
des des clients comme le bon marché les
galeries la
faillette le printemps mais aussi tous
les départements St dans le monde entier
bien donc en fait les ST est en train de
de on est en train de faire notre
nouvelle révolution je sais pas comment
pris probablement on est un travail
d'équipeid TR savezan vous parz de Jean
co Jean disait il n'y a pas de hasard il
n'y a que des rendez-vous et sur ce
principe là qui est vraiment universel
on a beaucoup beaucoup
de de de connaissances qui se sont fait
les unes derrière les autres qui nous
ont permis de d'aller sur des projets
qu'on aurait pas soupçonné une seule
seconde oui vous étiez prêts finalement
vous aviez des compétences on a mis le
temps moi je suis arrivé en 97 d'abord
pour faire un tout petit résumé mon père
donc avait pris l'entreprise à a
développé cétait un moment où dans les
années 70 on portait plus de gants on
avait les importations les importations
lesimportation et donc du coup nous on a
continué et ce que l'on a fait c'estf
c'est mon père qui l'a fait c'est sauver
l'entreprise se mettre dans
l'administration police gendarmerie
Pompi Armée de l'Air armée de terre
fanfare Garde
Républicaine l'école de Saumur l'école
de saint-cir les gants blancs bien sûr
beaucoup de gants blancs le gant aussi
beur frais le gant cadre de l'armé et et
ça ça a sauvé l'entreprise donc il est
passé de 350 employés à 90 ou ça on
arrive dans les années 90 et et il a
fait un petit peu de maroquinerie aussi
parce qu'il s'est rendu compte que des
acheteurs par exemple des nouvelles
galeries acheter les G acheter les sacs
donc comme dans la vallée du tard n nous
sommes il y a beaucoup de cuir donc du
coup il s'est mis là-dedans et donc tout
ça nous a permis d'être sauvé et puis
après on a fait un peu d'Oron on a
essayé d'Oron on a essayé un petit peu
de de faire attention pour les dépenses
faire attention pour le développement et
mon frère et moi donc avons repris
l'entreprise en 97 enfin lui est arrivé
un petit peu avant moi Mo 97 là on était
reparti à zéro et c'est assez difficile
parce qu'il a fallu dans un premier
temps trouver les clients donc moi j'ai
fait un petit tour comme ça en France et
pu fallait redonner envie bah là plus
personne ne portait de gants pratiement
donc tout était vierge voilà il y avait
un atelier à relancer il y avait du
personnel à reformer il y avait des
clients à chercher il y avait une
collection
ACC et sur un système un modèle qui
était le gant qui qui était plus dans
une tendance de protection du froid que
dans une tendance de mode donc Olivier
concrètement moi j'ai envie d'un peu de
concret comment est-ce qu'on choisit ces
gants quel usage différents usages au
fil de la journée est-ce qu'il y a des
tailles est-ce que ça existe sur
mesureou Oui oui alors bon bien sûr il y
a des donc la cliente quand elle arrive
ou le client quand ils arrivent en
boutique bon ici on est à Versailles
dans la cour des centeurs mais on a
aussi à Palais Royal à Paris le flagship
même si c'est beaucoup plus petit c'est
notre flagship et donc flagship le le le
le porte- drapeau en fait et donc du
coup la vitrine et donc du coup bah les
clientes ou les clients leur demande
leur taille s'ils savent pas on voit
avec la pointure des chaussures parce
qu'il y a une correspondance entre les
mains et les pieds quelle est votre
pointure en chaussures 39 et demi 39 et
demi vous faites un 7 et demi en même si
j'ai les mains un peu larges oui oui
parce que de toute façon c'est
légèrement élastique le le gant donc il
y a la longueur de do longueur qui
compte il a la longueur il y a la
largeur après il y a des modèles on a
des modè
voilà
nous vous avez les pieds tellement large
non on va pas lui parler des pieds on va
lui parler et et donc du coup on va lui
dire partez plutôt sur ce modèle ou
celui-ci après il y a la la doublure si
vous voulez un modèle chaud un modèle un
peu plus froid il y a du doublé
cachemire du doubl so donc il y a des
gants qui servent à protéger du froid et
au printemps donc c'est juste pour la
beauté alors au Pr il y a le gant pour
faire par exemple du golf il y a le gant
pour faire de l'quitation il y a le gant
pour pour conduire une voiture pour un
gant pour conduire parce que c'est un
côté très chic c'est un côté un peu
suranné il y avait l'époque bien sûr
c'était les volants en bois qui était
donc très chaud et pour éviter de
glisser et la chaleur avec le soleil on
avait forcément des gants quand vous
avez un cabriolet aurez même besoin
maintenant quand vous rentrez dans votre
voiture qui étaé chauffée à on a besoin
des gants aujourd'hui pour tout soyons
clair pour tout peut-être pas pour
dormir parce que c'est bien de garder
quand même le toucher ah oui à l'époque
on avait les mains très douces avec ça
on a aussi les gants parfumés et les
gants parfumés fonctionne très très très
bien alors oui quel quel pourquoi pour
le plaisir ben on a fait les gants
parfumés parce que c'est la racine du
parfum on est dans la cour des senteurs
ici donc on avait besoin de faire ce
lien d'ailleurs pardon Élisabeth de fedo
l'historienne a écrit un très joli livre
sur Jean-Luc Fargeon le gantier et
parfumeur de Marie de marie-anttoinette
et nous avons fait et avec élisabelle de
fédau on a consulté c'est quelqu'un qui
est vraiment avec une connaissance
incroyable du sujet on a on a créé les
les les gants parfumés de
Marie-Antoinette qui sont inspirés d'un
modèle existant que portait la reine qui
a été vendu aux enchères en 90 à la
pointe Cornélie ici on a refait le motif
quo la corn c'est une machine en fait la
Cornélie et puis on a fait les gants de
Joséphine pour le bicentenaire de la
disparition de l'impératrice que nous
avons présenté au musée de la M maison
de projets qu'on a mené avec la Réunion
des musées nationaux et comment on
choisi les parfums des gants alors on
est parti spé et ben bien on a essayé de
faire de l'historique donc en
l'occurrence Jean-Louis Fargent faisait
pour Marie-Antoinette et le roi les le
parfum ha d'ange qu'elle utilisait pour
ses gants et ses mouchoirs et donc le
parfum au d'ange est sur une note de
rose légèrement vanillé et on a retrouvé
la recette avec l'iffff et domitil
Bertier la recette précise et donc on a
talqué avec du tal parfumé encapsulé la
capsule éclate avec le parfum avec
mouvement et chaleur quand on met les
gants ça dure à peu près 3 semaines
c'est ce que vous dit et après on peut
rajouter le tal voilà pour l'instant on
l'offre le tal les gens reviennent pour
taler mais après on va commercialisé
d'ici le mois de novembre c'é un petit
peu long il y a des autorisations c'est
normal et on va proposer et quand je
vous disais en démarrage pour conclure
que euh les roses ma grand-mère avaiit
un sens jusqu'à aujourd'hui puisque donc
son prénom mais au-delà de ça euh
Joséphine son prénom c'était rose
Napoléon n'ait pas ce prénom donc la
rebaptisé Joséphine donc on a fait un
parfum pour les gant parfumés sur des
roses naturelles avec une rose turque
d'parta et une rose de syriie de Damas
qui a été ramassée au mois de février
fin février à cette époquel les roses
sont très parfumées presque confituré et
puis Joséphine marie-anttoinette c'est
bien sûr au d'ange donc avec une rose
vanillé et puis on a fait les gants de
la Belle et la Bête donc pour le les 50
ans de la disparition de Jean cocto qui
était notre voisin enfin bon c'est
plutôt nous qui sommes venus là où il
était au Palais Royal et l'histoire
était liée au fait que le le père de
belle avait ramassé une rose pour pour
belle dans le jardin de la bête donc du
coup cétait fait arrêté par la bête et
c'est le film secré là-dessus et donc ça
faisait beaucoup beaucoup d'histoir
autour de la Rose écoutez j'ai
l'impression que c'est sans fin c'est
sans fin c'est merveilleux soyez les
bienvenus merci et oui rendez-vous ici
cours des centeur Versailles pour en
apprendre encore plus et voir tout ce
qui existe ça donne juste envie de
porter n gants merci Olivier merci à
vous